bon sordide à conserver loisel voir ici
voici donc un taratata à taratata que
nous espérons prestigieux mais nous
sommes à peu près certain qu'il le sera
toutefois je voudrais qu'il le fut
encore davantage et j'ai remarqué qu'on
présentait en réalité très très mal les
variétés on nous traite un peu par
dessus la jambe les chanteurs sont
présentés comme ça à la va vite
j'aimerais que l'on prenne taratata pour
une émission sérieuse une émission
importante aussi importante par exemple
que le ciné club dimanche soir sur la
seconde chaîne
ça s'est présentée c'est expliqué chacun
y trouve son compte alors ce soir une
rions pas nous présentant taratata
comme si c'était une émission sérieuse
tout d'abord l'aspect créé mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs bonsoir c'est
l'heure maintenant de retrouver jacques
chance partagent chaque martin qui va
vous présenter trader donc c'est ma tata
comme chaque jeudi soir bien sûr ce soir
parmi une pléiade de vedettes une étoile
au firmament de taratata
il s'agit de il s'agit de marc de mike
brant mike brand qui est née un 2
février 1947 et dont la carrière
internationale a laissé des souvenirs un
petit peu partout
mike brand qui en 1969 craie laisse moi
t'aimer en 1971 ma prière qui ce soit on
va interpréter vient ce soir
et toi mon enfant mais je ne voudrais
pas retarder votre plaisir et sans plus
tarder je vous présente chaque martin
qui lui même est un grand spécialiste de
marque de mike brant
c'est bien en effet ce soir nous allons
donc aborder le cycle mike brant qui est
mike brant
c'est un chanteur né dans une île qui
arrive un jour en france qui apprend
notre langue et qui chante en 1967
je t'ai aimé tu roules à la veux tu
souviens toi j'étais bretonne puis ce
sera sa tournée en amérique ce qu'il y a
de spécifique dans l'oeuvre de mike
brant
c'est peut-être cette tendance sous
jacente à un art 6 6 me freudien qui
contrebalance les pesées psycho
analytique du personnage sous jacent
mais je ne voudrais pas que nous
écoutions mad band sans peut être
demandé à un spécialiste qui le connaît
particulièrement il s'agit de monsieur
kiki 2 nous avant que nous passions mike
brant et bien ce siècle avait 47 ans
lorsque dans une ville qui n'étaient pas
espagnols l'enfant mike brant parus et
le cercle de famille applaudit à grands
cris ses principales oeuvres qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il y à de
passionnants si vous voulez dans les
oeuvres principales où est le changement
dans l'oeuvre de mike brant et bien il y
à une évolution comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure
psycho freudienne sous jacente entre
laisse moi t'aimer 1969 à une belle
année qu'il avait enregistré avec pète
gordon à la batterie geôliers paca à la
basse et les frères glas pied au piano
entre mais dans la lumière mais dans la
lumière que tu meurs si vous voulez
peut-être moins s'ils reviennent que les
autres mais qui a je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous écoutez je ne
suis pas non il y a dans l'eure j'ai lu
j'ai lu dans dire une chose qu'au second
tour frei michel blue stream une pensée
de l'écrivain qui dit mike brant island
si je ne te fera une niche de hyundai à
niveau de vie qu'est tuque et nook gay
nook qui est d'écouter nous allons
écouter mayron nous en reparlerons tout
à l'heure nike brand